how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we do
have some major mcu news concerning
spider-man 3
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
including a list of familiar heroes who
have reportedly already signed contracts
to appear in marvel spider-man 3. and
not to mention some rumors going around
that miles morales could be making his
mcu debut in spider-man 3 as well and
then we also
have a list of villains who are said to
be making appearances in spider-man 3
some we've already seen from the mcu but
some that we've seen
from other universes as it turns out the
avengers tower may
actually turn into the ozcorp tower very
very soon
and to end it all off with a bang it
seems like we have figured out what dr
strange's primary role is going to be
and how exactly he's going to help peter
in spider-man
3. so i'll break it all down in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe for a chance to win this
week's giveaway which is an
iron spider funko pop to enter just
subscribe like this video and leave a
comment down below
so it does look like a full-blown
spider-verse is going to be happening
in spider-man 3. however whether or not
that's going to take place throughout
the entire movie or just a small part or
just at the very end
is unclear doctor strange is officially
confirmed to be in spider-man 3 taking
on the mentor role
for peter parker the role that tony
stark once had now obviously doctor
strange deals with the multiverse and
doctor strange 2 is going to be all
about the multiverse and how it's in
madness and then you top that off with
the confirmed news that jamie foxx's
electro from the amazing spider-man 2
is going to be in spider-man 3 as well
however it doesn't stop
there over the past week there have been
many different reports from many
different sources stating that toby
mcguire
and andrew garfield will both reprise
their roles as their respective
spider-man
and appear in spider-man 3 with tom
holland so over this past week fandom
wire reported toby maguire
and andrew garfield are signing on to
reprise their respective spider-man
roles for the upcoming spider-man 3.
editor-in-chief of geeks worldwide has
said they haven't officially signed the
deal but kevin feige is interested
and grace randolph of beyond the trailer
said what i'm hearing
are andrew garfield and toby maguire for
spider-man 3. they've been in talks for
a while
and it's almost official but toby
maguire is kind of plain hard to get
so of course everybody is just super
pumped that we could be getting the true
live-action spider-verse in spider-man 3
and it gets even better because last
night fandomwire.com did report that
according to what they have found out
toby maguire and andrew garfield have
officially signed on
to reprise their spider-man roles and if
that wasn't enough to get you super
excited about it there is a possibility
that miles morales
could appear in spider-man 3 as well in
fact it does seem like it is confirmed
that miles morales
is going to be entering the mcu last
night in a report from mcu cosmic.com
they stated that they've heard from a
credible source that miles morales has
actually already been cast
they went on to say they don't know who
marvel has cast only that marvel
has cast a miles morales but his mcu
debut in spider-man 3 would make a ton
of sense especially if you're going to
be introducing andrew garfield and toby
mcguire's spider-man characters as well
and let's not forget that miles actually
already does exist in the mcu
in spider-man homecoming we met aaron
davis played by donald glover aka
childish gambino aaron davis is the
uncle of miles morales and
even mentioned his nephew in spider-man
homecoming and of course there was even
that deleted scene for spider-man
homecoming where aaron davis calls
miles on the phone there are many ways
to include miles in the mcu but if we're
doing a spider-verse in spider-man 3
there could be a very good chance that
that could be his official debut
and you have to wonder if we're going to
have tom holland spider-man
andrew garfield spider-man toby maguire
spider-man and
miles morales could we also possibly be
getting a spider gwen
this would make sense considering the
fact that marvel is trying to include
more female superheroes
and of course it is confirmed that
olivia wilde is going to be
directing a female spider-man movie now
at this point in time it's actually
unconfirmed who the main character is
going to be whether that be spider gwen
or spider woman and it's unconfirmed on
whether or not it's going to take place
inside of the mcu although she did
hint a little bit that it will take
place in the mcu so the timing of all
this makes you wonder if indeed
will be getting the debut of spider gwen
or spider
woman now as far as the actual plot goes
in a report last night from
fandomwire.com
they said that nick fury is going to be
making his return
and of course that makes perfect sense
because in the post-credits scene of
spider-man far from home we saw nick
fury
he was on what was assumed to be the
peak the headquarters of
sword the space counterpart to shield
and according to fandomwire.com
nick fury's new galactic version of
shield which fans of the comics known as
sword will be involved in the film which
imply epic galactic repercussions of the
spider-verse being introduced so
spider-man 3 is shaping up to be an
extremely important movie for the marvel
cinematic universe but we don't just
know about the heroes that are returning
we know a little bit about the villains
as well
now if marvel's plan is to have multiple
spider-man in one movie then you can bet
that their plan is to have multiple
spider-man
villains in the movie as well
fandomwire.com reports that craven the
hunter will in fact be in spider-man 3.
this is something that we all already
assumed especially considering the fact
that the writer of the craven movie said
that craven will fight spider-man in
that
solo film so it looks like his feud with
spider-man is going to start in
spider-man 3.
so that's a villain from tom holland's
main mcu
sp umc universe then we have a villain
from
andrew garfield spider-man's universe
and that of course is electro
but in the new report from fandom wire
we have a toby maguire spider-man
villain coming in as well
and that of course is the green goblin
and ozcorp
fandomwire states that the green goblin
will make a return however it is unclear
if willem dafoe will be
inside the green goblin mask since the
character died in the sam remy films or
if the spider-verse timeline will
explain that
they also say that this version could
also be the version from the amazing
spider-man 2.
however they do go on to say that ozcorp
will finally make its first appearance
in the mcu
many assume the avengers tower was
purchased by oscorp and while
phantomwire cannot confirm that final
piece just yet they can confirm ozcorp
will be a reality in spider-man 3.
now oscorp happening in spider-man 3
could actually be part of the main plot
for a lot of people having the
spider-verse appear in spider-man 3 is a
dream come true
but at the same time many people were
hoping for a film that is just mainly
focused on tom holland spider-man but i
actually think that's still what we're
getting yes there are many different
possibilities with the multiverse but i
do think marvel is still going to try
and focus on tom holland
i think that the multiverse is only
going to show up for just a small part
of the film
and if i had to guess i would assume
that it's going to be at the end of the
film
we've heard reports that one division
will tie into spider-man 3 and then
spider-man 3 will tie into doctor
strange and the multiverse
of madness which of course is confirmed
because doctor strange is
in spider-man 3. so if the multiverse
will be in madness and doctor strange 2
it will most likely
explode into madness at the end of
spider-man 3.
i think when we enter spider-man 3 the
multiverse may be kind of broken and i
think this may be due
to the blip perhaps some characters that
were snapped out of other universes end
up getting snapped
back into our main mcu timeline and this
could be how we first see characters
like elektro
then gradually throughout the film we
could see other villains pop up as well
and then
by the end of the film when everything
is bursting into madness doctor strange
could introduce tom holland spider-man
to toby maguire's and andrew garfield
spider-man
along with any other spider-man that we
may get now at the core of it all in
spider-man 3 there still lies a
problem and that is everybody knows that
peter parker is spider-man
and this is where doctor strange could
really come in handy there is a story in
the comics where peter parker's identity
gets revealed
and peter parker doctor strange tony
stark and
mr fantastic decide to erase everybody's
memories of him
this could be why doctor strange is in
spider-man 3 besides the multiverse
aspect to it
because the problem has to be solved
people can't know that peter parker is
spider-man
so doctor strange could come in and
erase everybody's memory
of peter parker being spider-man now
it's a pretty big deal in the comics and
isn't that
easy for doctor strange but the movies
tend to change things a little bit and i
think helping peter parker deal with
everybody knowing that he is spider-man
especially the enemies is going to be
doctor strange's primary focus
at first in spider-man 3 until the
multiverse
explodes this would focus more on tom
holland's peter parker
then at the end of the film the
multiverse could be set up and a true
spider-verse film
dedicated to itself could begin that way
we get everything we want we get a movie
focused on tom holland and then we get a
live-action spider-verse but we'll have
to wait and see
what is to come for tom holland in the
marvel cinematic universe so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spider-verse news and let
me know your preference in the comments
down below would you like a full out
spider-verse movie in spider-man 3 or
would you like it to be focused more on
tom holland and then have a separate
spider-verse movie
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always this is warren and thank you
all so much for watching woof
you